direction l'inde maintenant on parle
souvent des industries de haute
technologie dans un tout autre registre
voici un autre secteur d'exportation qui
répond à une mode occidentale en plein
développement celui des cheveux naturels
ils sont rasées dans les temples en
offrande aux dieux récupérer traité est
vendu les mèches font fureur à londres
ou à paris
la route du cheveu reportage arnauld
miguet dominique marault tél
sharon stone monica bellucci ou ophélie
winter elles portent toutes le dernier
accessoire à la mode
l'extension de cheveux naturels mais
avant d'arriver sur la croisette il faut
parcourir 6000 km
tout parent fait du sud de l'inde nous
sommes au temple de chick à tirupati ici
les pèlerins ne viennent jamais les
mains vides
on apporte au dieu vishnou toute sorte
d'offrande fruits fleurs ou argent
certains sont même capables de faire un
don de toute autre nature
leurs cheveux au salon de coiffure du
petit en pilier affluence non pas que
ces garçons coiffeurs sache manier le
couple joue mieux que d'autres
c'est pour s'attirer les grâces de leur
dieu que ces indiens offrent leurs plus
belles parures je donne mes cheveux car
je veux que mes voeux se réalisent faire
un voeu remercier d'un souhait exaucé
les coiffeurs peuvent braz et jusqu'à 30
personnes par jour sans que ça ni savon
homme femme ou enfant parce qu'il avait
prié ici-même il y a trois ans pour
avoir une petite fille et qu'elle est en
bonne santé à sittard garde ses cheveux
tomber
yanni son père ne savent que ces belles
mèches seront revendu aux enchères et se
retrouveront dans cette cuisine à 100 km
de là à bengalore tous les mois 5 tonnes
de cheveux arif qui s'y mesurer nettoyer
ils sont ensuite les infectés maillot
belle sarah a monté cette affaire il ya
cinq ans c'est depuis le numéro un d'une
industrie étonnante et lucrative son
chiffre d'affaires 4 millions d'euros
par an 250 employés pour trier ses
cheveux par taille dans un silence quasi
religieux
ils seront ensuite revendus 600 euros le
kilo en chine aux états unis ou en
europe
besson c'est un marché unique parce que
c'est un produit unique qui provient
d'offrandes dans nos temples et ça c'est
bien indien si on est capable de tout
recycler le cheveu produits
d'exportation phares de linge direction
paris ce grand salon de coiffure ceylac
atterrissent les messes indienne envie
de changer de tête d'étoffer sa
chevelure ou d'ajouter de la fantaisie
le marché de l'extension représente 80
millions d'euros par an trois débats
maingain cette chanteuse ce bonheur
d'avoir une qualité de jeu
extraordinaire et trois quarts d'heure
et 1000 euros plus tard le sacrifice
indien n'aura peut-être pas encore
contenter les dieux mais il aura
sûrement rendu une femme heureuse